alors la meilleure façon d'apprendre à
faire du vélo et courir les notions
voyage dans le passé sur le parvis de la
gare de saint quentin en yvelines à
l'occasion de la fête nationale du vélo
des bicyclettes venue d'un autre temps
rouler sur le bitume ce samedi 2 juin
on retrouve cet esprit cet esprit un peu
pionniers cet esprit un peu inventif un
peu délirant même peut-être pour
certains ce que c'est vrai que la forme
de certains vélos sont assez atypiques
et on a plus remarqué déjà la tête de
certaines personnes en disait en disait
long sur leur leur étonnement et leur
surprise de voir des vélos qui qui
roulent encore malgré certains qui ont
près de qom cela par exemple 200 ans
presque donc c'est vrai que c'est assez
impressionnant sur l'après midi une
vingtaine de têtes brûlées se sont
testés sur le parcours le geste fut
parfois hésitant l usage des pieds
recommander certains novices ont même
tenté de s'associer d'autres se sont
même décourager avant de monter sur la
scène et ont préféré rester dans la zone
spectateurs
moi par contre je pourrais pas quelques
pilotes au contraire n'ont pas eu froid
aux yeux au moment de se lancer rien
actions plus difficiles que d'autres
mais après moi je sais que j'ai toujours
et je fais du sport j'ai fait du surf
donc bon niveau d'équilibré pas trop de
soucis l'activité est très ludique elle
mélange les générations et je ne
connaissais pas du tout ce type de vélo
dont je suis très content de cette
découverte et de l'accompagnement qui
est fait par les sympathiques animateurs
les participants pourront maintenant se
tester avec des vélos moderne sur les
400 km de pistes cyclables de saint
quentin en yvelines